il y avait une première urgence c'était
l'urgence budgétaire et de moyens
injustice on avait un ancien garde des
sceaux qui parlait de clochardisation de
la justice vous souvenez de ça et quand
on est
juste iciable on se rendait compte aussi
de la lenteur des difficultés
voilà bon les moyens on les a mis on
continuera à les mettre sur 10 ans sur
les deux mandats les deux mandats du
Président Macron et donc les deux
législatures ça va être presque 60%
d'augmentation du budget de la justice
c'est pas rien mais une fois qu'on a
parlé et je vous rejoins en partie une
fois qu'on a parlé des du budget il faut
parler de réorganisation
de moyens qui sont affectés au bon
endroit et tout ça c'était c'était ce
que moi je salue dans le travail des
états généraux de la justice c'est que
c'était un vrai travail autant des
professionnels de tous les
professionnels de la justice mais aussi
des citoyens français qui ont été un
jour ou l'autre confrontés à la justice
et ces de la justice et le président
sauvé ils ont fait un travail
remarquable je trouve de priorisation et
là maintenant le garde des sceaux les
apprises à son compte et c'est normal il
va falloir que ça se décline et nous les
législateurs il va falloir qu'on soit à
l'écoute maintenant des des juridictions
pour faire le la fin du bon travail qui
est commencé je trouve alors vous allez
alors on en est aujourd'hui et alors et
où est-ce qu'on où est-ce qu'on sera à
la fin en fait ma question c'est 11
milliards en 2027 ça nous placerait où
quoi est-ce qu'on remonte vraiment dans
le classement on remonte mais ces
tableaux ne prennent jamais en compte
une donnée c'est qu'en France on a une
particularité importante c'est qu'on a
aussi la justice administrative et la
justice administrative dans notre pays
elle fait un gros gros boulot tout le
contentieux d'urbanisme le contentieux
environnementale et aussi pris en compte
essentiellement par la justice
administrative elle est pas dans ces
chiffres d'accord et j'aimerais bien
qu'un jour quelqu'un fasse le tableau
moi j'ai essayé de le faire c'est pas
simple ça demande beaucoup de temps
pour qu'on ait vraiment que le budget de
la vie administrative le le sujet de la
justice administrative qui sont des
fonctionnaires aussi et qui ne sont pas
dans cette ligne là alors maintenant
comment on va faire comment le garde des
sceaux le gouvernement les
parlementaires le Sénat et l'Assemblée
on va avoir un certain nombre de textes
qui seront de l'ordre du règlementaire
et c'est le c'est le garde des sceaux et
la Chancellerie qui va qui va régler ça
et nous on aura quelques lois de
programmation et loi à mettre en place
en tout cas une chose est sûre c'est
qu'il faut de l'argent mais il faut
aussi certaines réorganisations et les
annonces du garde des sceaux sur la
réorganisation par exemple plus de
déconcentration des ça veut dire quoi
aujourd'hui et c'est l'exemple qui
prenait le garde des sceau et que moi
j'avais eu que j'avais eu aussi en
discutant avec les juridictions chez moi
et le tribunal de Quimper c'est que
parfois vous avez un matériel qui
dysfonctionne et il fallait remonter par
Paris pour que la décision soit prise de
le changer par exemple sur la vidéo sur
la vidéo pas surveillance mais vidéo les
c'est un exemple concret ça c'est
souvent des des sources d'économie de on
serait organise et puis il y a tout un
travail qui va être fait aussi mais qui
sera plus de long terme et qui je pense
donnera sans doute plus de facilité au
magistrat c'est la recodifification d'un
certain nombre de codes le code de
procédure pénale on va s'y mettre ça
c'est un deuxième temps mais
j'espère que l'enjeu
des moyens financiers il faut des
magistrats alors justement
ces projets aussi il y a la question
effectivement en 5 ans on va recruter
plus de magistrats que dans les 20
dernières années en 5 ans donc
franchement oui mais c'était la question
mais ça va changer quelque chose pour
les Français je vous dis non mais bien
sûr que ça va changer de la même façon
que ce que le garde des sceaux appelle
les sucres rapides et qui sont les
fameux contractuels bon je suis désolé
il y avait une levée de bouclier contre
ces postes au départ aujourd'hui il y a
pas beaucoup de présidents de tribunal
qui va vous dire enlever les mois ils
sont contents qu'ils soient là et on va
les on va les on va pérenniser ces
postes là on va les institutionnaliser
on va leur donner un statut et tout ça
va dans le bon sens et effectivement le
magistrat pour qu'il fonctionne bien il
a besoin d'une équipe et c'est dans les
10000 recrutements il y a aussi tous
ceux qui feront partie de l'équipe du
magistratif les il y a 1500 magistrats
et 1500 greffiers c'est ça le chef et il
reste 7000 bah 7000 j'imagine que c'est
tous ces personnes qui font un travail
formidable et qui vont être
institutionnalisés qui seront des aides
juridiques importants le le juge il a
besoin d'une équipe alors on rentrait
dans le détail du juge dans ce pays qui
est le juge solitaire qu'on voit dans
les dans les séries non un juge
aujourd'hui s'il veut bien fonctionner
il a besoin d'une équipe
aujourd'hui
former des juges on va en former plus
mais faut savoir aujourd'hui le nm ils
sont dans des algeco donc parce que
parce que pour aller plus vite on a on a
dans le budget il y a aussi un volet
justement sur le Nm pour l'agrandir et
pour avoir des bonnes conditions ensuite
vous parlez de l'avoir accès aux juges
bon moi je veux bien on a parlé des
moyens je crois que tout le monde
reconnaît ici qu'il y a des moyens
financiers qui sont conséquents et qui
même s'ils sont du rattrapage et sont
énormes et que c'est très bien il faut
continuer maintenant vous parliez de le
citoyen il va avoir accès au juge et bah
parlons-en et quand on fait par exemple
le cette nouveau système de développer
l'amiable en passant par la césure
c'est-à-dire que c'est le juge qui va
dire le droit et en laissant après aux
parties de trouver les méthodes de de de
compromis pour
que chacun
en réalité paye son dû si je me permets
de parler un peu crûment le juge va dire
le droit aujourd'hui c'était pas c'était
les gens attendent longtemps avant de
voir le juge là ils vont le voir
beaucoup plus vite et ça va mieux
fonctionner parlons de la justice
un retour du terrain le mais le retour
du terrain de quelque chose qui est pas
encore mis en place ça va être difficile
ça va être difficile aujourd'hui vous
avez des parties sur un sujet un
contentieux de de l'immobilier de
logement
le juge la personne va attendre très
longtemps va s'agacer les deux parties
vont ça va aller dans le stock ça va
emboliser les services l'idée c'est
d'aller plus vite et de dire le juge dit
mais c'est vous qui avez raison c'est
vous qui avez tort reste vous vous
avez maintenant un mois pour trouver une
solution sur le règlement de ce conflit
voilà et après dans un mois je reviens
voir du juge se réduit avec c'est le
principal reproche qui est important moi
je peux pas laisser à partir du moment
où on va avoir une justice qui
fonctionne mieux avec des juges qui ont
plus de moyens le pouvoir du juge va se
renforcer dans ce pays voilà mais
aujourd'hui je suis désolé je suis
désolé aujourd'hui pour le coup le juge
n'a pas de pouvoir dans ce pays
aujourd'hui il est mal il est mal aimé
parce qu'il est trop lent mais je suis
désolé moi c'est les ressenti que j'ai
et je suis sur le terrain et aujourd'hui
on parlait du du garde des sceaux le
garde des sceaux il va dans beaucoup de
juridictions en ce moment et il y a une
différence entre effectivement peut-être
les syndicats et les leaders syndicats
parisiens et la réalité sur le terrain
il est accueilli aujourd'hui et il suce
et son plan suscite l'espoir donc il
faut il faut continuer et en plus on a
des moyens énormes on a des
réorganisations qui vont dans le bon
sens c'est pas parce que des magistrats
à ont un contentieux avec un homme qui
qui on peut pas avoir des des a priori
comme ça voilà moi j'avais pourriez-vous
cacher j'ai travaillé avec
Dupont-Moretti j'ai été le premier
rapporteur d'un texte du premier texte
qu'il a porté j'avais pas je le
connaissais pas j'avais pas un a priori
favorable défavorable ce que j'ai
rencontré c'est quelqu'un qui écoute qui
bosse et qui a qu'une idée c'est la
réussite de la justice parce que le
temps 15000 places supplémentaires c'est
pas c'est
utile et nécessaire parce que c'est pas
15000 c'est 15000 là c'est des
rénovations c'est aussi donner des
conditions dignes pour les personnes qui
sont en prison aujourd'hui nous on a la
chance quand on est parlementaire enfin
je sais pas si c'est une chance de
pouvoir aller dans les prisons comme ça
comme on veut pour contrôler je peux
vous dire c'est terrible et donc il faut
qu'on il faut qu'on ait une des actions
politiques fortes sur le sujet 15000
places supplémentaires ça répond à ça
déjà ça répond à des meilleures
conditions mais ça veut pas dire qu'on
retombe dans le tout prison parce que à
côté de ça on a fait beaucoup de choses
pour la mise en place des peines
alternatives et il faut continuer
ensuite moi je suis très sensible à
cette idée d'avoir des typologies de de
prison c'est à dire que suivant les les
cas suivant les peines suivant le moment
de la de l'emprisonnement aussi parce
que parfois les peines longues la fin de
la peine n'est pas la même que le début
il faut qu'on ait des il faut qu'on ait
cette typologie différente en tout cas
en tout cas en tout état de choses
aujourd'hui on peut pas se satisfaire de
la situation telle qu'elle est c'est
terrible et et les prisons françaises ne
sont vraiment pas la gloire de notre
République et on ne peut pas laisser
faire ça moi j'entends et la réinsertion
l'accompagnement éviter les sorties
sèches chez primordial la libération
sous contrainte ça va dans ce sens ça
prend effet au 1er janvier et vous la
saluer
je ne salue pas parce que je vais
marcher c'est un aménagement de peine
décidé en trois mois vous ne pouvez pas
comment dire fonder les conditions d'une
voie d'insertion exactement il faut un
an et donc c'est pour ça aussi la
régulation député c'est-à-dire on a trop
de gens en prison on les fait sortir
trois mois avant comme ça on règle et on
peut en faire rentrer d'autres
en tout cas c'est certainement pas
l'idée d'ailleurs moi je suis oppose à
cette idée d'avoir un humérus clausus
dans les prisons parce que ça serait un
chèque en blanc pour pour certains
bandits de savoir il y a plus de place
en prison je peux y aller là
non soyons sérieux par contre le Garde
des Sceaux est une volonté aussi de la
majorité c'est de développer massivement
le travail en prison c'est à dire que le
travail en prison qui permet l'insertion
qui permet l'accompagnement et qui
permet aussi de donner et on l'a fait on
a créé un statut du prisonnier
aujourd'hui les prises jusqu'à
maintenant les prisonniers avaient un
statut qui était un peu je veux dire un
peu lamentable là ils ont un statut ils
ont des des choses qui leur permettent
de travailler un peu plus sereinement il
faut aller dans ce sens là parce que
l'inactivité en prison c'est terrible
alors il y a le travail il y a le suivi
il y a les